bon avec nous maintenant pierrefitte ce
qui est bonne le ministre de l'économie
de l'innovation bonsoir monsieur
critique est bonne pour cent au dessus
de lyon alors pourquoi réinvestir dans
ce tournoi est de nouveau avec tout ce
qu'on a connu les pertes bien sûr qu'on
a connu un moment aussi où les
conditions de marché sont encore
difficiles quand même ou avec télé les
tamponnais stratégique quand on se
rappelle que quatre partenaires bas sont
loués à caisse de dépôt il ya aussi ce
qu est très proche langues
les actionnaires ou principalement au
regard des nouvelles approches
techniques pour au prix d'usiné ont ce
qu'on a constaté que c'est qu'on peut et
ou payer les unes avec des coûts
inférieurs de l'ordre de 20%
pourquoi parce que on va retarder un peu
de développement et pouvoir y met les
revenus avec les dépenses affectées pour
30 millions de dollars d'investissements
sur une base de quelques années
aujourd'hui avec la réduction de coûts
on pourrait avoir un point bas donc on
pense à 440 emplois qui vont être mis en
place donc c'est une décision prise par
les actionnaires
ok les actionnaires avec des missions
économiques ont trouvé que c'était une
bonne proposition
donc point mort break even en anglais
c'est à dire c'est le moment où on
commence on peut espérer commencer à
faire des profits à ce moment là mais le
prix du diamant avait quand même chuté
de façon très importante on en est où
est-ce qu'on atteint justement le niveau
du point mort dont vous parlez vous avez
raison la dernière transaction qui a eu
lui était au mois de mars 2020 et le
niveau de la transaction de près 58
dollars soit d'éducateurs et maintenant
les coûts de production ou vont être
réduits à peu près ce niveau là donc si
on croit qu'on est rendu au point
minimum pour marquer un point mort mais
pas pour lui non plus par contre que
l'autre alternative était de maintenir
en hibernation là même qui en soi a
coûté 15 millions $ par année donc ont
accosté aux actionnaires qui ont des
fins commerciales et caustique seul
investissement qui valait la peine
ce à quoi on a acquiescé et nous allons
financer le gouvernement 50% de cette
demande là l'autre 50%
l'actionnaire privé parce que vous
considérez
qu'aujourd'hui on va commencer pour vrai
à faire de l'argent avec cette mine là
là qu'on se retrouvera pas dans une
autre situation où on faire justement
des sommes restructurés à sion et cetera
c'est le bon moment et on va faire de
l'argent avec ça c'est ça que tu es
l'argent golfeur doit être modeste parce
que nous avions trop au choix les
mineurs aient pu être abandonné
complètement donc pu retourner en
arrière
scénario qu'au correctionnel voulait
considérer l'autre scénario ça devrait
rester en hibernation encore un coût de
15 millions $ par année il toise et le
scénario c'est de mettre 30 millions de
liquidités qui va nous permettre de
faire un point noir est un peu d'argent
et aussi d'avoir quand même 440 emplois
qui vont être mis nu donc chers ch'tis
pas aujourd'hui qu'on va récupérer de
l'argent qui est investi on sait qu'il
ya eu 3 5 millions d'appartements
destinés réponse je peux pas dire ça et
aujourd'hui sont fait un point mort
petit profit et qu'on a à 3 440
personnes dans la région
je pense que ce projet qui mérite d'être
au chaud vous avez annoncé aussi à la
fin du mois d'où la reprise avec tard
lingers de nemaska lithium ça aussi on a
quand même perdu pas mal d'argent public
dans cette aventure là également
jusqu'où il faut aller sur facebook est
bonne dans le rôle de l'état pour
relancer cette d'activités qui ont
certainement beaucoup de potentiel mais
qui sont et on le voit la très risqué
vous avez absolument raison d'ailleurs
je pense que quand je regarde nemaska
1.0 faut admettre c'était sa beauté taux
d'échec que financier on a vu deux
bogeys aux actionnaires qui ont quitté
l'entreprise
on a vu le management on a vu la
direction essayez trouvait sur une base
planétaire des gens qui étaient pour
investir le juge
regardez avec le processus à gravats
personne ne s'est pointé
donc effectivement nemaska 1.0 était un
échec et le gouvernement du québec a
perdu malheureusement 80 millions de
dollars qui avaient été investis au
préalable patente à gosse je vous
souhaite
c'était une situation était désastreuse
d'ailleurs juste pour m quand le
management a annoncé qu'il y avait eu
une hausse de l'ordre de 40% des
dépenses pour le projet
dans l'énergie peu de temps après sont
venus voir et ont annoncé votre juillet
2019 qu'ils investiraient 600 millions $
dans le projet moi j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer le président par ailleurs le
jeu devrait encourager fortement
investir malheureusement car ils ont
regardé sous financière on ne descend
2019 ils ont dix jour aucune
considération nous pouvons investir dans
des masques à 1.0 donc ce n'est pas par
choix le moi moi moi je porte je suis
trop de 80 millions de dollars d
investissements qu on aurait dit qu'on
le veut maintenant pourquoi continuer
c'est la question dont constat gager
avec tiger tu te mal à 95 millions
chacun pour repartir par les girls c'est
un sas est éjecté lisons font un
britannique qui se spécialise dans les
minerais pour les batteries alors
constat qu'on a un bon partenaire
on n'a aucune idée encore combien
d'argent vont être dépensés en avance
dans le projet et on va voir avec notre
partenaire comment ont pu évoluer le
projet de lithium qui a cessé ses
partenaires là disponibles par ligne est
ok pour commencer ce suffisant pas rien
c'est un partenaire très sophistiqués
ils ont regardé ma score en détail les
nommer ce coin 0 ils ont passé six mois
le regarder ils connaissent l'industrie
ils connaissent le graphite ils sont
déjà actionnaires de nouveaux mots
exacts moi je crois que je crois que ce
partenariat avec le gouvernement va de
votre projet de division économique
tirer un chantier important de minérais
ou batterie seul le monde.fr
il faut pas croire qu est ce que vous
dites quand même aux actionnaires aux
25000 petits actionnaires qui se font
entendre qu'ils disent on a investi de
bonne foi dans les masses canaux perdu
des millions de dollars on pensait qu'on
serait considérée par l'état par le
gouvernement du québec
on a perdu beaucoup d'argent puis on
n'aura rien là de la nouvelle mouture de
nemaska qu'est ce que vous leur dites et
je suis totalement d'accord avec la
frustration je suis très désolé pour eux
je la mets une situation avec 80
millions $ à chaque québécois vidéo
investissement québec à 10h dans les
mascottes et que le management
le conseil d'administration
- mars 2019 on a 2 décembre 2019 au
parcours ul-haq laine pour trouver un
investisseur était pour aller de nemaska
ont trouvé personne
après un mois de janvier le juge avec un
receveur regard des différentes
alternatives personne s'est présentée
la seule façon de maintenir des masques
à la seule c'est que le gouvernement du
québec comble l'écart financier qui
étaient de l'ordre de 1 milliard et je
pense avec plus que sordo ça même prêté
une considération s'arrêter le manque de
rigueur complet la part du gouvernement
d'investir seul dans un projet qui
requiert une expertise que numéro pas
mais au final et je comprends ta de vos
explications il ya quand même des
milliers de petits actionnaires au
québec qui se disent nous allons
investir dans une entreprise québécoise
avec un fort potentiel nous croyons que
ça vaut la peine
mais aujourd'hui ils n'ont rien ils sont
très déçus de l'action du gouvernement
par rapport au jeu je comprends
parfaitement leur leur position écouter
le problème se situe ailleurs un faut se
questionner sur la nature des projets
comme celui là la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est est ce que ces projets là
devraient des sociétés publiques
ce qu'on a demandé au public d'investir
1 du projet le projet le projet de
lithium au bâti ça va coûter 5 à 7
milliards
je ne pense pas ce sont des projets pour
les investisseurs de détail qu'on
appelle je pense des projets pour des
gens cet échec à lorient une caisse en
questionnement qui est beaucoup plus
large que les masques or on ne lui
aurait dit qu'on ne veut pas que
d'entreprises
bon je pense qu'on va falloir se poser
des questions et j'encourage les
actionnaires de démasquer a continué
leur la procédure parce qu'effectivement
il ya eu des problématiques noms des
mascottes
on va savoir ce qui était responsable
moi je vous dis aujourd'hui que le
gouverneur était irresponsable
d'investir plus d'un milliard de dollars
comme seul pourvoyeur de nemaska un coin
0 alors que tous les investisseurs
sophistiqués du monde entier refusait de
rester dans une structure qui était
déficiente à l'origine parfait merci
fait ben merci pour cet entretien ce
soir merci